Duct tape can hold
just about anything together.
We use it for all sorts of repairs
and even as a decorative addition
to various arts and crafts.
But what makes duct tape
so strong and versatile?
And is it duct tape or duck tape?
The tape was originally called duck tape
because of its water-resistant qualities.
It repelled water like a duck's back,
and it used to be made out
of a cotton duck fabric
without any adhesive layers.
But cotton duck fabric doesn't
actually come from ducks.
(squeak)
This is what it looks like.
It's a strong fabric made from cotton,
where the threads make
a crisscross pattern.
Known for being a strong
material, the fabric was used
to protect power cables
and electrical conductors
from corrosion.
But the adhesive duct tape
we know and love today
didn't appear until World War II.
A factory worker who
was packaging ammunition
sealed each box with tape and
wax to make them waterproof.
When the worker, Vesta Stout,
saw soldiers struggling
to open the boxes, she
came up with an idea
to seal the boxes with a strong
cloth-based waterproof tape.
Stout wrote a letter to
FDR about her solution
and, a few weeks later, received word
from the War Production Board
that Johnson and Johnson would
be manufacturing the tape.
The tape became a military sensation.
It was durable and easy to
apply and remove by hand.
After the war ended, duct tape
turned up in hardware stores
ready to help Americans
with household repairs, too.
It quickly became a useful
tool for wrapping air ducts,
which led to its other name, duct tape.
Duct tape used to be kind of
a one-and-done silver tape
that was essentially used for repairs.
Our adhesive is specifically
formulated to stick to
a whole variety of different
surfaces, and then basically
the waterproof backing on
top of that then protects
the adhesive once it's
applied to a surface.
Narrator: There are three main components
that go into making the tape.
Rubber for the adhesive,
cloth, and backing.
The rubber comes from rubber trees
and arrives at the factory in large bales.
A machine mixes the raw rubber along
with various sticky
resins until it reaches
the consistency of pizza dough.
Then, the mixture is heated to
over 200 degrees Fahrenheit.
Now the adhesive is ready to be added
to the cloth and the backing.
The cloth, sometimes called
the scrim, lies in between
the sticky rubber layer and
that ubiquitous silver backing.
It's made from cotton and
is a key part of the tape.
The cloth is what gives the
tape its tensile strength.
It makes it easy to hand
tear and keeps the tape stuck
to a surface once it's laid down.
Finally, there's the backing.
The backing is made from polyethylene,
the same plastic material
used to make bags
and shampoo bottles.
Once the backing is ready,
all of the materials are put together.
So there's basically two ways
that the backing can be
incorporated into the tape:
either laminated or co-extrusion.
The co-extrusion basically
melds together the backing,
the cloth, and then the adhesive.
So it gives you a stronger
tape that won't delaminate.
It's gonna be really good in
different weather applications.
Narrator: Once the layers are combined,
the strength of the cloth
and the plastic-like nature
of the backing combine to
give the tape the strength
and durability we know and love.
The tape comes out in one jumbo
roll that weighs over a ton.
Each giant roll can produce
over 30,000 small rolls.
To get it to a smaller size,
the roll is sliced into strips.
Then, the smaller tape strips
are put into cores and rerolled.
Finally, the tapes are placed
in their final packaging,
sent down the conveyor belt,
and put into boxes for shipment.
Since its debut, duct tape
has exploded in popularity.
Today, we use it to make
flowers, bags, wallets,
science projects, and various DIY crafts.
Unlike your masking tapes,
scotch tapes, painter's tape,
and other single-use tapes,
duct tape has a long history
of being used for just about anything.
By simply putting fabric
and adhesive together,
Vesta Stout may have created
one of the most useful
and strongest inventions we have today.